we're in problem 248 truly the home
stretch right triangle PQR is to be
constructed in the xy-plane
let me draw an XY plane it seems like it
should be useful so that's X and then Y
I'm sorry that's why and that's X let me
label them since I set them wrong Y and
X that should be second nature to you at
this point okay right is constructing
the XY plane so that the right angle is
at P all right
and P R is parallel to the x axis okay
so it's going to look something like
that where you know that's P and that's
our problem today and P is the right
angle right so it's going to look like
something like that so Q has to be right
below P okay the X&Y coordinates of P Q
and R are to be integers that satisfy
the inequality - 4 is less than or equal
to X which is less than or equal to 5
and it tells us that 6 is less than or
equal to Y which is less than or equal
to 16 how many different triangles with
these properties can be constructed okay
so let me let's let's just first draw
this range right so X could be between
minus 4 and 5 so f could be between
minus 4 and 5 and x and y are always
going to be integers so that's kind of
our boundary and it could be minus 4 or
5 right and then Y is between 6 let's
just say this is 6 and 16 y is between 6
and 16 okay so let's think about this so
let's let's think about where we can
place the point so first of all how many
different legitimate places can we point
can we put the point P how many places
can we put the point D let's just kind
of figure out how many different ways we
can construct this thing so if we have
to pick its x-coordinate how many
different x-coordinates are valid so we
have minus 4 minus 3 minus 2 minus 1 0 1
2 3 4 & 5 right it should be what 5
minus minus 4 should be
and one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten Oh actually no it's ten
different points because we could
include minus four right so it could be
X could be minus four minus two three
right this is minus 3 minus 2 minus 1 0
1 2 3 4 & 5 right so this x value could
take on all right any of these 10 spots
all right so P can take on 10 different
values P well it's x value could take on
10 different values right Soapy's X can
take on 10 different values and how many
values can it's why take on over
well we this top boundary is 16 this
bottom boundary is 6 and we can be
either 1 right so 16 minus 6 would be
you know 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 but
we can include 6 as well right if you
just send 6 minus 16 minus 6 that would
give you 10 spots but since we're
including 6 the Y could take on 11 spots
right you could count them maybe it'll
be beneficial for you to to see all of
the different Y's it could be it could
be anything between 6 and 16 including 6
and 16 so there's 11 possibilities for
the Y so that means that there are 110
different possible pees right all right
let me just draw one of them let's say
that's our P so if our P is there how
many different for any given P how many
different possibility ours are there
well R is in the same line as P so
whatever P's Y value is R has to be the
same but our could be to any other of
the other leftover X spaces right so if
P took up one of them are could be here
it could be here it could be here R can
be in any of these spots right so how
many left over x spots are there well
there were 10 x Botts 10 x coordinates P
took up one of them so now our R could
only be in one of one of nine x
coordinate right R can only be one of
nine x coordinates fair enough
all right and and
our is limited to its why I mean once we
pickle once we pick a y-coordinate for P
that's got to be the same coordinate for
our right R it has to be on the same
y-coordinate as P right because they
told us that this line is parallel to
the x-axis
fair enough so how many possibilities
once we've pick in a P and it picked a P
and an R how many different
possibilities do we have for Q well Q is
going to have the same x value right
because they told us that this is a
right angle and it says that this has to
be Q so Q has to be in the same in the
same vertical line as P has to have the
same x value and so how many different Y
values can it have well there were a
total of we said there were originally
eleven potential Y values right that's
what we said when we picked our P P
could be anywhere between 6 and 16 Q
could be any of those numbers but it
can't be at the same point as P right
the side has to have some length so if
there were 11 original slots 11 original
Y slots P takes one of them up so then Q
could be any in any of one of 10 Y slots
10 Y slots so if we want to know the
total number of potential triangles like
this there are 110 potential places to
put P once we've put P there are nine
potential places to put R and once we've
put P there's also ten potential places
to put Q so this is 110 times 90 110
times 90 that's the same thing as 11
times nine with two zeros right so 99
two zeroes which is choice C choice C
and we're on to our last I'm glad this
is a new video that took me six minutes
problem 249 hopefully won't take you
that long in the g-men it takes less
time if you don't have to explain it if
N is a positive integer less than 200 so
n is less than 200 it's positive and
it's an integer and 14 over N 14 n over
60 is an integer is an integer so that
means that 14 n divided by
60 or 49 is divisible by 60 then an has
how many different prime factors so now
let's simplify this first divide the top
and the bottom by 2 you get this is also
saying that 7n over 30 is an integer
okay well multiplying by 7 doesn't make
it any easier to be divisible by 30
right because 7 and 30 share no common
factors 14 and 60 did too but we got rid
of it so you have 17 and 30 so n has to
be divisible by 30 right and has to be
divisible by 30 for this to be an
integer right well I don't know let's
just pick the smallest one I mean
there's a lot of different candidates
and could be 30 or 60 or 90 or a bunch
of different numbers but let's just pick
n is equal to 30 they don't say they
just say that n is less than 200 so
let's just say that n is equal to 30 if
n is equal to 30 then they say how many
different positive prime factors well
let's just do a prime factorization of
30 it's 2 times 15 just 3 times 5 so it
has three positive prime factors so
that's choice B I don't know I'm just
curious let's see if that would have
worked if we picked n equals 60 n equals
60 if you'd have done the prime
factorization of 60 you've gotten 2
times 30 it's 2 times 15 which is 3
times 5 and yeah you still have only 3
factors you're using one of them twice
so this is the same thing as 2 squared
times 3 times 5 so you still have
actually 3 different positive prime
factors so it'll work for any of the
multiples of 30 anyway choice C and
we're all done I don't know what I'm
going to do next maybe I'll do some LSAT
videos or or maybe I'll get back to
actually teaching something anyway see
you in a future playlist